I really appreciate it but it's never
I'm sorry what is there a moment where
you recall like how you bounce back from
your first heartbreak absolutely that's
I mean this is one of my favorite like
themes up to all the boys is like don't
be afraid to love don't be afraid to
love in the first place
or again you know and absolutely I think
the first time I went through a
heartbreak know I know the first time I
went through a heartbreak I was
terrified that I was never gonna recover
yeah you really don't think you're going
to you're like alright that's it my god
I found my one and like everyone else is
never gonna be able to top that and I
was wrong yeah you know I was so wrong
and you do recover you do heal and you
actually can bounce back and be even
better and learn from it you got to tell
people how you feel when you feel it to
all the girls that you once loved what
would you say to them now just say thank
you Dave Lee that's good that's a really
positive way of thinking of it and it
means that you've really learned from
your first love I don't think you can
really take anything from somebody he
truly was oh my god okay get ready to
fall hard for Noah synteny Oh as Peter
into all the boys I've loved before how
our fans gonna fall in love with you and
they see this character they know Peters
a bit of an egotistical guy but he also
like underneath the surface of him
looking like a jock he actually really
cares and he's respectful and he's
sensitive soft teddy bear on the inside
hard shell on the outside speaking of
love you were also a love interest in
Camilla Kibeho Havanna video tell me
what it was like working with her it was
so incredible
they like dress me and this really like
tailored blue suit and put gold chains
and rings on me and slick my hair back
in like I look the part you know I'm
standing like and then they take me to
set and I meet her she's just this like
vibrant like little loving creature you
know like in the most endearing way
creature hobby lawyer I guess at that
she's like like vibrant energy you know
and she's so kind and I like sat next to
her my home we watch to do a couple
takes and she's so talented we did our
choreography we learned our dances we
did the bits and then that what that was
that you know I'm quite an experienced
man she's so talented she deserves
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]